well welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies Oh God
this is a juggle at beauty pageant yeah
nice women make sure that face covers
the whole screen all right a lot of
people think Jeff Lutz are just like
they're just these big whores
now
when I go to the gallon drinking shows
and other girls we can just sit and be
girls
you're not preppy you're not gonna judge
me for anything like we can sit down and
have a one-on-one alone conversation and
relate to so many things in so many ways
that not any other people can really
relate to
oof if I was a judge and those were the
first few people that came up on the
contest my score would be Oh wolf but
can I tell you well how much would you
love it if one of these broads showed up
at a legitimate beauty contest that's
true that would be then I started
watching Miss America all over again is
one of these lunatics showed up yeah
yeah can we do that can we subvert a
beauty pageant like that yeah I mean
like I guess that's kind of what they're
doing
yeah um so that's sort of the the my
point of it yeah I like y'all right yeah
that's cool but still score well all
right come on why is that not stress
that was such a dad thing like uh-huh
uh-huh now do it
what do you think your dad would say
about these ladies oh you'd be really
upset this is your first gathering so my
dad my Ben this is your first beauty
contest no I won 2009 really
yeah I need a microphone disappear
where he made in the front of the bag
yeah Wow so she put a microphone in her
couch yeah that's pretty cool actually
I'm a bigger fan now I respect that my
dad would be really upset by this too
Oh should this woman laughs loudly God
fuck fucking the fun
look at these pigs only gum well my
father has no tolerance for unattractive
women yeah disdain for unattractive
people like how dare you be ugly yeah
fat too right Oh fatness is ya know an
excusable yeah he always makes jokes
about me he's like does he he's always
like I see you lost some weight I'm like
oh yeah he's like nah this is a miss
cyanide here talking about her last year
our journey started with you cyanide a
jugglin trapper who lives in her home
studio with her boyfriend fat kid
okay
ten feet tall can't break me down yeah I
bet they're gonna hate me now there's no
safety now hey
so so far I'll say I'd rather watch her
compete in the beauty part than the
rapid heart point taken
now in a the concert is between Nick
Hawk the guy from the real Plastic
Surgeons of Beverly Hills or a deejay
pork rind whatever her name is miss
cyanide miss cyanide which of these
concerts now listen you got to go you go
watch the whole show so we have Nick
Hawk doing his rippity raps we have the
Beverly Hills plastic surgeon is like I
dedicated a lot of times when you're in
surgery you need something to go wrong
otherwise what are you there to fix yeah
that guy he's like okay he's last
all right I just I just decided he's
last I think he's last I think it's the
hardest one because here's why it's bad
but it's bad in something that I that
wouldn't necessarily like if it was good
you know it's not even your John right
so just so I feel like I could have a
lot more laughs and a lot more fun even
with it being bad at Nick I know that no
that's the problem is that there's so
much more to laugh at and it caught the
Nick Hawk show yeah cuz he's gonna be
you know posturing real since leg saying
yeah yeah yeah miss cyanide is just kind
of sloppy and all over the place yeah
what I've seen so far
mm-hmm she's a little more polish yeah
more time take me down I bet you're
playing in this song now
it was rad this is more about haters and
the shit that you deal with people
because I'm I'm up here I'm feeling
great I'm on top of it I'm doing what
you said I couldn't do yeah cyanide is a
contestant in the juggle at beauty
pageant that's held on the last day of
the gathering every year all right
no I like this I like the cyanides going
for it I like this lady too and I will
say of all three at least she's really
kind of in it like she's genuinely one
thing I'll tell you I like more than at
this than I do at traditional beauty
pageants is that they're really doing
this is obviously the talent portion
mm-hmm
so far we know that one of them raps and
one of them shoved the mic up her cooch
right and I would rather see that at
Miss America than that bullshit when
they look yeah it's fucking and I flip
this in the air and then I catch it you
know when that'd be the best if they're
like I can hide this in my pussy yeah
like there's like and that's miss Iowa
yeah that'd be great
yeah thing I understand it's to subvert
beauty pageants the one then why have a
beauty pageant at all like would that be
the ultimate subversion is to just not
have a beauty pack well no because I
think in this case what they're saying
is those beauty pageants are so
misguided and and and their
interpretation of beauty so
one-dimensional that we're gonna bring
women to the table that aren't
traditional beautiful right and the one
who shoves a microphone up her pussy is
like manner clear lean over the rapper
or the other talents you know kinda cool
sure last year sian I participated for
the first time she kind of blew it
but she's been practicing all summer to
get back on stage good for her I'm
really nervous and I got really really
fucking high like before I was like I
got smoked a bowl and my brain was like
all fuck you forgot the rest of your
lyrics I like her
yeah hey you know why she saw her
mistake she knew how to correct that and
she's gonna move on actually the thing I
respect the most is that she went back
that's yeah good for her dude
that's tough huge fan of cyanide already
I wouldn't want to watch raps that long
yeah everyone has um has fucking as a
comedian forgotten the line you for sure
panic inducing it's the worst
that's why I don't do drugs I can't even
really drink coffee before shows I don't
like to do anything before either yeah
do it straight but she learned that
cyanide pack 300 jello shots and most of
the belongings in her home before
setting off someone might not have a
good second year at this yeah maybe get
together which she and fat kid had been
saving up for all year uh man this is
like their whole life no they love it
she's spending it on jello shots good
for them gassing up the van fat kid and
I are gonna go rippity rap all right ah
man I'm actually really into this now
yeah um I like this look actually do you
think serious I like a mohawk I've
always liked Timon you have always liked
are you gonna do it to our son no you
don't like the kids yet can I tell you
something I don't like to inflict my
personal style on a kid it's like unless
he asks for it yes not my place I know I
like The Ramones does my kid have to
like The Ramones no yeah it's not an
extension of me he's his own little dude
yeah yeah do I want to put clash shirts
on my kid yeah but I won't it's his
fucking he's a good person
yeah I know Michael people do that oh
fuck this always happens to me
um you don't like doing that at all
right it's just not fair
it's like he didn't ask to be a fan of
the shit that I like yeah um here we go
we have an outdoor party with DJ clay
which is gonna be quite the Sun holy
shit just paint oh yeah ha ha ha more
like we can do a lot of really ratchet
stuff about getting in trouble after
yes exactly gears awesome that'll be
here and what about that tattoo what
about that is my for this is what I'm
talking about now I didn't realize that
these were just like soggy underwear
that he's wearing I thought this was an
actual short and I'm not so much into
the front of the outfit I'm into the
back of it though but what about this
part of the front yeah I like that I
like that I like what it stands for
that dudes rad huh super it's a lot of
crazy tattoos here is this a grenade on
his hand yeah yeah yes I like it she's
just like hey what's up she's like yeah
this is normal he's like this is how I
roll
actually well GG Allin look I'll shout
out he's wearing out the same GG if you
combine he's the girls clip from earlier
about eating ass uh-huh you look at this
yeah I feel like a lot of what she said
would come true in here mm-hmm
it wouldn't smell great wouldn't taste
the best right but overall not that bad
not that bad yeah what do you think
miles better than it used to
I think this guy's got the worst ass of
anybody in the world
no but bad was bad would you eat his ass
no I would not but I don't think it
would smell good either let's jump ahead
to um miss miss cyanide performance I
want to see yeah does she redeem herself
this year well here this is bright
before she goes up I think right here
poor girl
I hope she's been practicing in front of
audiences that's the key there's a lot
more people out there than last year
when I'm
when did this I'm like
Wow you can do it she's nervous come on
Batman come on come on homegirl um so
this is a clip here where let's see
there's some good sorry there's good
contestants this is the tattoo or is
this a drawing that looks like a tattoo
babe oh boy babe here she goes I got oh
I'm so invested in messiah night now
yeah I want to know what she does oh yes
participant kales something called
clothes shopton and she is miss cyanide
I'll tell you this already I like it her
live performance is better than her
booth performance you know when the one
that she did at home had a fraction of
this energy
well she's feeling it she don't know yes
she's fucking on it I think she's she's
killing the game my feeling is that so
she's she's feeling good about herself
Ryan now here's what you've been waiting
for genes the results are you ready we
have the results do you think how you
think she did I'd say she killed it but
knowing that last year someone put a
microphone up their pussy in one she's
gonna get beaten out by some dumb cunt
that does something stupid it was like
everything in showbiz yes right here we
go for 2,000
see
contestant number 10
mm well she did what she did I don't
know is that well why so what miss up
cyanide I'll vote for you
good job we support you well good for
her that's really hard to do now I
thought the Juggalos were supposed to be
non-judgmental yeah yeah but you're not
supposed to boo people offstage